accessorize for that beach party and try
these two drinks and honor of Barbie
Barbie herself we recommend starting
with a strawberry daiquiri which is
essentially a strawberry slushie with
rum some Citrus but we added some tart
strawberry coffee to enhance the
sweetness of the drink making it
specially for her for Ken start with a
Pina Colada mix of equal parts rum
coconut milk and pineapple juice but
also add some lychee juice or anything
tropical to give into personality and
make it feel special to you since these
are both rum based you can mix them and
they rule so go out there and get some
sun and some love and please drink
responsibly